I'm dating just for fun Sister Wives
star Christine Brown is moving on with
her life following her split from Cody
and she admits dating isn't all as it
seems you know that just keeping
everything super light because that's
just who I am right now I'm just gonna
keep everything like nothing serious mom
of six shared multiple pics of herself
posing in an all-black outfit while
revealing she's back on the market quote
I'm dating again holy hell awkward
dating online is crazy and asking any
advice for dating at 50. after
everything you've been through what is
it you're looking for in a new partner
um kindness
um real just kindness and romantic
relationship for sure someone's who's
attracted to me would be a really great
thing I'm just saying so yeah all of
that Christine and Cody ended their
spiritual marriage in 2021. I firmly
believe me was
willing everything
oh great and
and done so it's more like a personal
strength that I feel like I have more
than I've ever felt before repairs messy
split played out on season 17 of Sister
Wives
man just the knife in the kidneys over
all these years and the sacrifices that
I made to love you and their daughter
gwendolyn's watching it all back in her
recap YouTube series I guess maybe I'm
just in a state of denial you are yeah
and she's calling out her dad for
accusing their mom of pitting his kids
against him we were the ones that
convinced my mom are not really
convinced her but we probably dislike
our father more than she does it's not
fair for him to blame it on my mom when
he's the one that's not showing up I'm
probably the worst one in this situation
because I complained all the time about
how my dad hadn't showed up it's
definitely not my mom it was most likely
if anybody was feeding information to
her it was probably me but despite the
tension that Vans witnessed last season
Cody's wishing Christine nothing but the
best in her next chapter one of the kids
told me dad mom says you have your soul
mate
and she wants hers well I hope she finds
her soulmate so who's Christine's ideal
man well she revealed she's attracted to
This World of Warcraft character for a
specific reason duratan is an orc and
that's really what I'm attracted to the
first time you meet him well he's a
warrior but he's looking at his wife
with so much love and so much and he
would do anything for her and I just
want that kind of love Suki I just want
that kind of love yeah
[Music]
thank you